it's good to me
there's just no trust no TIG
so a loaded of the kids took my wife
body on and I moved on out to a Colorado
farm now it's early to bed early to rise
the crops are plowed and it's no
surprise city folks about Nana don't
give a dog
cuz I make my living on a call around a
bar I gotta drive the track you gotta
cut the grass chut chut goes the vaillar
legs never gonna last
there's food in the kitchen and there's
fun in the bar that's life living on a
call around farm ice-cold beer pickup
truck
country music listed we got Tegrity
to keep us warm that's what you get on a
call around a bar and I'm gonna stay on
a call around farms
you